this isn't this statistically impossible
that I always kept black against the sky
every came ok this is FM volver een I'm
black and it's the same story he always
has white against me ok I trying a from
tying a pig's defense i don't want i
want something different than the room
have had that against him so often ok
had already paid off getting some Kings
Indian so hmm let's go I 595 might be
good time but it's just playing instant
moves as usual ok can I give me the
bishop pan I'll go back whatever mmm
where are you going to eat six maybe I
don't know ok I'm going to f form after
years be conduced dark squares 92 f for
it looks quite attractive so um I'm
Bishop d7 I guess 97 rook c8 96 I don't
see much point in that ok i have given
up I've given up on this display you
just never never ever place anything
that I expect or find remotely logical
it's just sometimes it is like that they
sometimes if they think aren't
completely different I don't know just
totally differently check
check that's it for the night but you
played quickly and that it's nice i was
even quicker check to be honest mmm ok
yourself
where is your green going continuing
that Wow okay so some way to make them
they're probably not let's get the e
pawn going
okay i can still just play to e all
right yeah no particular reason not to
do it okay where's the cut da check
check check check hmm
yeah some stale still matrix maybe
stalemate a king age 79 trying to find
some kind of self self sale made doesn't
look very lightly though and also get
the deep on going and it's the last king
age 8 h 7
check Emma ticket politics Brooklyn
Brooklyn back and promotion that is
actually a stalemate quad funnier but I
can take here that's nice he actually
there's actually a trick em takes
politics look back promotion grouped
book g8 cellmate check
quite resigned yeah so as I said during
the game I didn't get much of that I
mean this is a totally uncia reticle
position earlier d 5 is completely out
of normal way how this is played and we
just have a complicated Kings Indian and
I don't get how you can't play or
everything in one second but okay it's
an old story okay so let's see Bishop
Bishop f6 is just a mistake I think that
gives me just me clear dominance on the
dark squares I'm not sure about c5
earlier but okay this is definitely
wrong txt so yeah I hear black is better
what is the comp giving 0.94 black yeah
it's probably fair I have a better
center which she gave me very easily EF
GF was instead plate and well I just
have a big center and two bishops this
is rubbish for wild 95-year okay I could
have played if for IE for us even
stronger yeah he falls even stronger
okay night air force certainly not bad
King here Bishop e7 and he just has to
go back now yeah I mean it's not it's
not nice but this is this is just giving
away upon and I still have a for coming
and the night is dominated and a half
like the complete complete center for
check check this is a piece you know
so Jeremy not much not much else to save
this is just a dash out opening after
which why it's basically lost not not
more not less okay well thanks for
watching